last year we saw the highest economic
growth of any G7 country that was in
2022 in 2021 we also saw the highest
economic growth the highest GDP growth
of any G7 countries so that's two years
in a row with the highest growth in the
G7 we've seen figures so far this year
on GDP that have come in a little bit
better than people had expected on the
question of unemployment we've got
unemployment which is mercifully uh
almost the lowest level it's been for in
my lifetime for nearly 50 years 46 years
so that the unemployment figures despite
all of the difficulties with the war in
Ukraine and everything else are
remarkably robust and better than many
uh European countries but there is a lot
more work to do that's why the prime
minister is relentlessly focused on
halving inflation growing the economy
and cutting debt certainly a lot to be
doing a lot to do on all of those but
but I wonder if we can focus on on your
brief for part of our time this morning
um clearly action is being taken by by
yourself and by the whole office to ban
machetes and those other knives the
zombie Knights which have no other
purpose than that no practical you
certainly explain the thinking behind
this well I've been approached by quite
a few MPS in recent months pointing to
constituency cases where people have
been attacked using these uh terrible
knives which as you say have no
practical use at all they're either a
double-edged machetes or zombie knives
with
um sort of sort of shapes and
protrusions which means when somebody
gets stabbed with them they can cause
very very serious internal injuries and
they're used to intimidate people in
Street muggings when criminals trying to
take a role at a watch or a mobile phone
and they're used in the context of of
intergang uh fights as well so we think
there's no no reasonable use for these
these weapons that's why we're taking
steps today to ban them I I suppose the
question has to be why is it taking this
government 13 years to ban big knives
well I mean some some of these knives um
were banned a few years ago we do have
amongst the strongest knife floors
anywhere in the world and since 20 you
mentioned the last 13 years in the last
13 years since 2010 violent crime has
reduced by 38 according to the crime
survey of England and Wales and cream
hasn't which is you're rather more
pertinent to what we're discussing today
look at the figures ons data 2021-22
says there were more than 45 000
defenses involving a sharp instrument or
a knife now that figure was nine percent
higher than the year before but compared
to 2010-11 it was 34 higher well I think
some of those recent figures are because
of the dip and then um increase
following covid looking at the last
three years one of the best measures of
what's happening with knife crime is
looking at Hospital admissions where
people are admitted into hospital with
an injury caused by a sharp weapon and
over the last
um I think three years for people under
25 which is a particularly concerning
cohort that's gone down by 24 and as I
say overall violent crime down to 38 but
there's a lot more to do and it's one of
the reasons why we're hiring more police
officers so um figures that are going to
come out next week we hope will confirm
we're going to have more police officers
than we've ever had at any time in this
country's history I'll just reiterate
that the difference in the figures
between 2010 11 and 2021-22 there were
34 more incidents of knife crime I mean
this government clearly hasn't got a
grip on it well I'd say overall violent
crime has come down
um we are taking action either Banning
these knives today we've taken action
previously we're going to have record
police numbers and overall violent crime
um has reduced but there is more to do
and today's announcements are part of
that work can we talk a little bit about
voted identification we are in the in
the run into the local elections of
course why are we making this change why
are we demanding people show photo ID at
polling stations when historically this
country has never had a problem with
voter impersonation but of course one of
the issues with voter impersonation is
you know by definition you don't know
when it's happening and when you can
turn up to a polling station as you
currently can and just say my name is
John Smith and I live at number 10
Acacia Avenue and that's it you just get
given the polling cards
well as I just said it's the kind of a
kind of thing where by definition it
doesn't get detected of course there are
plenty of times when uh ID is required
for simple things including collecting a
parcel or indeed voting in a labor party
parliamentary selection meeting a number
of other European countries have this
requirements you don't need to have
photo ID to be a candidate in these
elections but you need photo ID to vote
in them well you've got a you've got to
present information to the returning
office you've got to get like 10 people
to nominate you for example in fact for
parliamentary elections it's probably
more than 10 I forget the number
um but the the um the osce wrote a
report on the 2010 general election
recommending we take a look at this in
Northern Ireland uh the last Labor
government
2003 situation because of the
sectarianism that takes place there and
it's clearly markedly different but if
we look at the Electoral commission data
and all of this from 2022 there were
seven allegations of personation at
polling stations and in not one of them
was there ever was there anywhere close
to ever for them to proceed with it
there haven't even been prosecutions let
alone convictions so again I ask why on
the one hand you have the rights of two
million people without photo ID
potentially becoming disenfranchised and
you've got seven allegations of
personation in 2022 none of which
resulted in a conviction well I think in
order to make have absolute confidence
in the ballot I think saying you need
some form of uh ID in order to vote in
person on the day is a reasonable thing
to request there are 20 forms of ID that
are acceptable and we found that I think
98 of people have one of those forms of
ID and for the two percent that don't
there is a free form of election ID
which they can apply for and I believe
uh well over a thousand people a day
have been applying for this in in recent
in recent months so not including me
this morning and I I was rather
surprised to find that through this
process all you need to do is insert
your personal details pop in your
National Insurance number and upload a
photo I mean if that system is not
capable of being a a fraud is not
capable of being perpetrated through
that system then I don't know what it is
well I'm gonna say we have to put a
National Insurance number in now clearly
to have a National Insurance number
you've got to have gone through all
kinds of processes first of all to get
your National Insurance number clearly
that ni number will have been checked
against a government database now that
is very different to just turning up to
a polling station saying my name's Joe
blogs I live at number 10 High Street
and being able to vote which is what you
could do previously I completely
understand that but why then isn't a
Young Person's real card valid as a form
of identification for that you need to
show proof of identification in fact you
need to show more proof of ID than I had
to do this morning to get my vital well
I'm not sure that's true I think for the
young persons we've seen this example on
online of The Young Person's Oyster card
I think compared to the over 60 Oyster
card and one is valid and one isn't and
the reason is The Young Person's Oyster
card is has much much lower
identification requirements than the
over 61 which does require something
like a passport or a driving license uh
you know The Young Person's one does not
require a National Insurance number for
example
proof of identification but not to the
same standard as the over 61. look at
look at look at what well in Scotland
you have you you have the past that you
can use there but look at the list of
passes that the Scottish national
entitlement card which entitles you to
free transport on buses in Scotland if
you're under a certain age but look at
the cards that aren't allowed to be used
the older person's bus pass the disabled
person's bus pass the oyster 60 plus
card the freedom pass the national
entitlement card the 60 and over Welsh
concessionary travel card are all of
these for older people it does it does
rather beg the question is part of this
not to do with the fact that if you are
under the age of 25 you are far more
likely to be voting labor in the next
coming election nonsense I think the
studies that were done showed that
actually younger people were more likely
to have I mean the thing is 98 overall
so I mean it's most people have one of
these forms of ID but I believe the
study showed that younger people were
more likely even more likely to have one
of the various forms of ID than older
people so the point you're making I
think is categorically not not fair but
just just to just to reiterate this
point that are young people who have
student identification that they've
achieved through their local college or
their University there are young people
who have their real account where
they've had to show proof of
identification these people so it's like
so I get to do more but they need to do
more than they have to do online through
the voter Authority so young the study
showed that the young people are more
like despite what you said young people
are more likely to have one of the 20
forms of ID than older people so your
suggestion that somehow young people are
going to be unfairly disadvantaged is
categorically not true of anything it's
the other way around but the main point
is that 98 of people already have one of
these forms of ID that just means two
percent of people might not be able to
vote but they can apply for the free
identification as you did and hopefully
you found the process for
straightforward and easy very easy very
easy in fact good to talk to you this
morning thanks for being with us okay